as humans we have a strong need to feel
like the masters of our own fate and
when your freedom of choice is
threatened it creates an arousal in the
body and brain and the motivation to
react ultimately compelling you to do
things you're told not to do like
watching this video let's try a little
thought experiment please don't think
about a white bear right now
oops you're probably thinking about one
studies that give participants the same
instructions and have them think out
loud for five minutes buy that on
average the white bear appears in their
thoughts not only at the onset of the
experiment but once every minute this
automatic compulsion manifests in more
concrete ways as well
like the literary world where the
attempted banning of books has often led
to them being more successful
seriously books like The Great Gatsby
Catcher in the Rye and To Kill a
Mockingbird are some of the most
frequently banned books in the world yet
some of the most successful so why can't
we help ourselves the impulse comes from
the perception that we're losing our
freedom and is a psychological behavior
called reactance have you ever been told
you couldn't have something only to
realize that it made you want it more
when in the first place you've never
even really wanted it a classic example
is the limitation of alcohol consumption
in the late 80s when the u.s. increased
the legal drinking age to 21
a study of thousands of people found
that those affected by the new law had
higher than expected alcohol consumption
compared to their legal age counterparts
studies have even found that there is an
increased interest in entertainment
programming when it begins with a
warning the your discretion is advised
our curiosity is a powerful force which
has led to the successful rise of
clickbait on the internet titles like a
wealthy person lost all their money you
won't believe what happened next gives
you essential information but leaves a
gap in the knowledge that you must
fulfill known as the information gap
theory were primed to want to fill in
the blanks this taps into our
psychological and physiological response
in fact studies measuring pupil arousal
show that if you're more emotionally
aroused from a headline you're more
likely to click it and we put up with
clickbait because well sometimes it
works some
times we get the satisfaction and
release of dopamine we wanted by
satiating our desire to fill in the
information gap which makes your desire
to collect next time even stronger in
the same way when we disobey rules we
can also find pleasure and a surge of
dopamine which creates positive
reinforcement you may also be a
genetically predisposed rule-breaker
Studies on twins and adoptive children
have shown how your genes play a large
role in how impulsive you are in general
people with lower levels of baseline
serotonin where seem to have increased
impulsive behavior which led to breaking
the rule with all that said don't you
dare go watching more ASAP science
videos you're simply not allowed I'm
putting this playlist right here but
it's not for you and you better not
subscribe for more weekly videos every
Thursday we won't see you back here then
I
[Music]